згон камеру тримає Андрій Луганський і
вони всі знову це роблять от скільки вже
можна Андрій Привітай привіт привіт всім
привіт скільки вже можна здавалось би це
робити але будуть робити будуть робити
поки є така велика потреба зараз ви
бачите як чоловіки грузять вже готові
набори продуктові ми з вами запитати чи
є звук бо ЗНО так Я щось забула почала
стрім Напишіть будь ласка чи є звук
картинка оцініть від одного до 10ти звук
і від од до 10 картинка я включила чат я
включила так і напишіть будь ласка чи
видно нас чи чутно бо я щось вже погнала
робити стрім забула
запитати а подивись на телефоні
зараз секундочку 10 10 А звідки да 10
треба А звідки ви пишіть ще з якого ви
міста
теж все працює все є класно тут вже
чоловіки ви бачите грузять готові
продуктові набори в цю Прекрасну
вантажівку на якій Навіть є Цьомка така
красива червоненька бо вона із одесси З
любов'ю розумієте ця вантажівка вона
сьогодні поїде в Одесу і доставлять
продуктові готові набори в Одесу частина
залишається в Києві частина їде в Одесу
зараз опрацьовуємо дві області я одягаю
з вами масочку це в мене термос такий
смішний в руках я пила каву рокову свою
і
ми з вами разом Ідемо всередину я вам
покажу там у нас купа волонтер
які зараз оголосили перерву тому ми
одразу ж скористались можливістю щоби з
кимось поспілкуватись поки перерва ми
маємо таку якби можливість з кимось
поспілкуватися зараз я зніму пальто Я
так думаю бо тут в принципі дуже
спекотно розкажи поки я зніму паль
швидень вони знов це роблять це знов
конвеєр поки перерва поки тут не гримає
музика Ми вирішили зробити стрім поки ми
ще встигаємо зараз хвилинок за Я не знаю
5 1015 все почнеться
знову зараз уже робота кипить і вже
майже півфури завантажили Марія прибігла
Тримай я до вас прийшла нали сьогодні
прохолодно вчора було значно тепліше ось
ці всі коробки які ви бачите вздовж
стіни розставлені це не декорація це ви
не повірите буде все запаковано сьогодні
отам величезна стіна а тут була ще одна
величезна стіна яку вже частково
розібрали бачите вона вже стала меншою
бо була аж туди майже до стелі діставала
це все коробки які будуть сьогодні
спаковані це рахунок можна вам скинути
грошіють люди е там мають прикріпити в
описі до цього стріму
зараз модератори які дивляться цей стрім
Вони мають прикріпити там реквізити або
ж скинути в коментарі реквізити всі
реквізити ви знайдете в описі до цього
відео Або можливо вже після стріму ви
обов'язково або звісно Заходьте на сайт
справи громад я вам прямо зараз можу
показати який це має вигляд ми зараз з
вами разом зайдемо на сайт справи
громадиться Я просто заходжу в
Google в Google і
пишу
справа Грома
і одразу ж перший лінк який випадає - це
го справа громад тобто дуже легко пишете
в Google справа громад і тут буде воно
так що це конвеєр ось
одразуж одразу ж
долучитись все тут все є вся інформація
Тобто ви можете це зробити буквально три
кліки як я зробила вже
зібрали 518 000 на
259 продуктови наборів сьогодні збираємо
2000 Сільки встигли закупити продуктів і
ось вони власне всі тут і
розкладені так тут Тут все є Звісно
зараз секунду це Приватна
інформація так ось паролі ішли це
скільки зібрано скільки витрачено тут
можна подивитись хто задонатив можна
клікнути сюди можна подивитись витрати
все що було закуплено і ось тут є номер
картки Ось він Я його можу зараз
скопіювати і закинути в чат Я так думаю
що
прибан Ось так
скопіюємо Ось є кнопка перерахувати
прямо на сайті або може лінк на сайт
скинути Я зараз скину лінк на сайт зайду
в чат ось є реквізити для тих хто з
інших карток Я вам копіюю зараз цей лінк
якщо мені дасть YouTube таку можливість
то я його скину вам в чат зараз і ви все
побачите Ось мій стрімчик Ось я стою так
бачу
себе Ану пропустив
ніби Зараз
побачимо не знаю напевно що пропустив я
попрошу модераторів вони скинуть ще
додатково що ж а Ми продовжуємо
власне Ось у нас продукти які всі будуть
спаковані продуктовий набір знаєте не
маленький абсолютно не маленький але
єдина От якби така нюанс наприклад
минулий продуктовий набір ми могли
дозволити собі покласти гречку цього
разу ми вже не можемо собі такого
дозволити тому що вибачте ціни на гречку
отакейні а нам треба зробити багато
продуктових наборів тому обрали трошки
інші продукти Але все може змінитися
якщо ви будете донатити ще більше коштів
тоді ми зможемо дозволити собі можливо
змінити вміст продуктового набору і
повернути туди гречку тому давайте
повернемо туди гречку разом переходьте
за посиланням на сайт і там ви все
побачите ось готують коробки їх
підклеюють це одна коробка це одна
коробка для одного набо
Давайте я зараз ще раз на камеру
продезинфікую руки щоб мені потім не
розповідали Марія Чого ти брудними
руками берешся хоча я їх дезінфікувала
Але я на камеру зроблю це ще раз Он там
є антисептик тут скрізь є антисептики
всі волонтери у нас
захищені
всі зараз швиденька сюди всі працюють в
рукавичках ось дивіться при вас
я чую запах да все запах спирту
присутній ось такий вигляд має набір
бачите вже частково спакований просто
конвеєр зупинили туди ще не поклали
олійку і ми зараз і подивимось тут що
тут у нас крупа кукурудзяна сквірянка
так
7.0321 виготовлена щоб потім не
розповідали що якісь там такі набори ее
до 22-го року аж Може вона собі
зберігатись Хоча я думаю що її з'їдять
значно швидше ячмінна
крупа
14.03.21го теж все свіженьке абсолютно
всі продукти свіжі
борошно ось таке навіть англійською
написано з цього боку З цього
українською
так ось воно
29.03.21 виготовлено теж всі всі
продукти за свіжість тут знаєте ми вже
несемо відповідальність за свіжість
продуктів і ми її чітко виконуємо всі
продукти свіжі ніяких нарікань у нас ні
того року не було я все показувала і все
це ж партіями привозять і цього року так
само
611.20го теж виготовлений цукор він може
взагалі довго зберігатись тому немає
проблеми і вівсяні пластівці розповідала
на одному із стрімів розповім ще раз
знаєте сама мала досвід їла більше року
вівсяні пластівці просто на сніданок
кожного дня і ну правда Я вже потім їх
так переїла що я зараз не можу їх їсти
але це було дуже корисно і класно
насправді на сніданок вівсяні пластівці
Я рекомендую Бо мені лікарі так
рекомендували робити гастроентеролог і
якби це було реально класно може треба
якось колись повернутись до цього але
поки що я не можу на них дивитись Тому
можливо іншим разом
9.04.21 виготовлені теж тобто все все
все швиженьке До речі Дивись як
прикольно стали робити на упаковках
qr-коди я такого ще не бачила
класно це сучасно так не аби там що
потім у нас іде це Воно якби коробка
пройшла по конвеєру вже свій шлях бачите
вона так совається добрий чоловік зробив
нам такий конвеєр тепер ми можемо тут
повністю робити такий більш
автоматизований процес потім є олія
соняшникова зараз олія теж дуже дорога
реально це проблема була знайти олію так
щоби закупити її масово і щоб вона була
не якась там дуже-дуже така знаєте
дешева така середньої якості
1.0321 середньої ціни українська Вона
майже вся одна українська В принципі
вона вся хороша так писали До речі в
коментарях Сполучені Штати що у них олія
Вони купують ходять в магазини де
продають українські продукти окремі тому
що у нашої олії взагалі Є смак і колір А
у тієї олії яка там то це трохи
проблематично це писали мені таке в
коментарях не знаю чи правда напишіть
якщо ви США свинина тушкована може
зберігатись дуже довго і в принципі таке
їмо з задоволенням
6.0425 може зберігатись Ну це ж якби
консервований продукт аж до 25-го року
Може зберігатись потім тут є ще для тих
хто можливо хоче додатково серветками
там щось протерти Ось бачите рукавички
нові поклали собі будуть
одягати потім є згущене
молоко
30.0321 першого теж виготовлено
зберігатись може я не знаю хто зна
скільки воно може зберігатись це ж
згущене
молоко 12
місяців але я думаю що значно більше
згущене молоко зберігається ну це така
моя думка і власне ще такого знаєте
приємносте Ну не просто там тримайте вам
крупу А ще чогось треба такого для душі
чогось такого приємного і от власне
печівко те що можна
30.0321 термін і воно до кави
йде класичний знаєте я от все дитинство
з бабусею я приїжджала до неї в гості і
ми з нею сідали на балконі там був такий
маленький столик і вона мені робила там
чай в таких чашечках красивих і з
серванту діставала чашечки і робила мені
печиво ось ось такого плану отаке печиво
робила із маслом і це було дуже смачно
тому ось це насправді дуже класний
інструмент Це дуже крутий інструмент
тому що він значно
полегшує швидкість роботи покращує
знаєте якість виконаної роботи ось тут
вони беруть скотч і якось там його там
отак чік роблять і все Ну це треба при
принеровитись але звук так від цього
коли тут зараз конвеєр працює і тут
багато людей
одночасно одночасно все це роблять
Чи це треба в нього запитати чи це не є
ітоги е
двохрічної роботи Зеленського що ми
знову робимо конвеєр хіба що я не зможу
стояти на вулиці холодно Віталій можна
на секунду тільки ближче до будівлі бо
холодно Так мені так нам
наприклад вам спекотно знаєш ось цей
конвеєр це ж мабуть і є результатом
двохрічної діяльності Зеленського правда
от Дворічна діяльність Зеленського на
посту президента Ти знаєш це не скільки
результат скільки наслідок
і Ну на жаль так і знову ж таки це як з
історії все доводиться робити самим якщо
Влада слухай мене вчора убив вчора чи
позавчора степановляпнов з приводу того
що треба було
нам ще пть років тому будувати завод для
вакцини від коронавірусу
точно Ну ти розумієш що це клініка от
просто тупо клініка тут треба не
висновки політичні робити а діагноз
доктора ставить тому що це це Тотал
невіглоси відповідно Якщо таке
трапляється в державі А хто буде там
надавати допомогу
тим кому немає до кого звернутися от
власне От так На жаль але так Хоча з
іншого боку знаєш перед перед революцією
гідності в Києві був жарт пам'ятаєш
березень 13-го року коли завалили всіх
снігом Ага от тоді коли народ почав
розгрібати сніг виходили в на нічну
варту виносили там канапки каву джиперам
які витягали машини і через півроку
стався сталась революція і тоді Кияни
жартували що ми тренувались на снігу щоб
потім прибрати юнаковича Можливо там
зараз там ситуація там дещо інакше
розтягнута вчасі але все це не
спростовує ключового коли громадяни
самоорганізовуються Вони тренуються для
того щоб рано чи пізно змінити владу яка
не здатна ні на що О так абсолютно
згодна з тобою Дякую Віталій коли в
Рівненську область повезуть а повезу
повезуть будуть і в Рівненській е ми
напевно будемо десь через тиждень тобто
тут виходить що в нас зараз Київська і
Одеська Сьогодні я так розумію потім
протягом Наступного тижня ми ж збираємо
наступну там наступний транш грошовий і
десь напевно в другій або в третій черзі
точно буде Рівненська область і також
буде
роздача До речі в більшому обсязі ніж
минулого року було Угу такгу Які відгуки
Минулого року стикнулись
а ти знаєш є відгуки хороші а є відгуки
погані і погані відгуки були в тому що
люди які ми ж збирали адреси людей люди
могли вільно зареєструватися на
платформі онлайн і сказати я потребую
допомоги і було дуже багато випадків
коли наші волонтери ходили з цією
продуктовою допомогою а їм відкривала
тетенька з Айфоном і казала дадада
мальчик заходи Давай заходи заходи вот
сюда Поставь мы кажем А где бабуля
бабуля Спасибо передаст и ти так знаешь
розводиш руками ти не можеш її забрати
але це люди відкрито зареєструвалися ти
приходиш до їхньої хати там дві машини
стоїть і ти розумієш що вони не
потребують цієї допомоги але
ПЛ любить халяву і і коли з одного боку
ти можеш принести цю допомогу і тобі в
лице плачуть з подякою бо обґрунтовано
до цієї людини ніхто не приходить бо
родичів або нема або вони на іншому боці
країни і вони не можуть добратися і Ти
єдиний хто прийшов допомогти і ти бачиш
так факт ця допомога потрібна але поруч
є історія коли благими намірами
меценатів благими намірами волонтерів
просто маніпулюють люди котрим ця
допомога не потрібна так от врахувавши
досвід Минулого року от цього року Так
ну принаймні там на Рівненщині точно не
буде ну я сподіваюсь що також в інших
областях теж ті хто будуть на логістиці
на виході власне опікуватися доставкою
до адресата вони трич перевірять чи
насправді цей адресат потребує цю
допомогу бо кожен халявщик який забрав
не потрібний насправді йому набір
допомоги по суті він вкрав цю допомогу у
тієї там літньої людини чи там людини з
інвалідністю чи самотньої людини вкрав
те що тій людині там рівноцінно життю
так як ві не соромно лостика буде через
партійні організації логістика буде
через партійні організації так логістика
буде через партійні організації просто з
простої причини що у нас мережа
партійців вона природня більша ніж
мережа волонтерів справи громад ну
власне і там де справа громад може
долучитися до логістики вона робить її
ефективнішою тому що це зайві руки Вони
ніколи не бувають зайвими але там де
справи громад мало Або вона недостатньо
активна в силу молодості осередку
природньо там весь тягар логістики буде
лягати на партійців так місцевих
партійців на місях Все чекаємо збору
наступної допомоги для Рівного і чекаємо
фотозвітів з Рівного Дякую Віталі все
буде це був Віталій
гайдукевич Що ж тут у нас
Що тут у нас можемо ще пройтись показати
наприклад
антисептики давайте рахувати по-перше
дивіться от маски так в пакеті
запаковані окремо Тут взагалі одна
штучка тобто все тут передбачено
абсолютно водичка це якби для волонтерів
які втомились фізично зрозуміло що це
така не дуже і легка праця
і треба це все встигати робити звісно
найважче тим хто працює скотчем найважче
тому щох поруч працює зі скотчем і хто
поруч працює зі скотчем Так бо воно
робить вжух вжух постійно також
фізично розкладати ось ці банки сюди
подавати але знаєте зробили от як як
могли як на досвіді Минулого року Слава
Богу досвід є і
зробили Такий процес що в принципі
виходить там вже можна показати там
величезна вже завантажена вантажівка
близько 400 наборів вже зробили тобто
хоча тільки почали а зробити треба
близько там чуть трошки більше 2
000 щось Такий дощик такий неприємний
моросить такий он там вони і ось Аж тут
аж тут аж тут вони всі розкладені тому
що найважче
робити Я навіть задумалась мабуть
підготовка найважча
Насправді я мало стосуюся підготовки Але
бачу як це все відбувається зсередини і
це дуже багато рухів дуже багато людей в
цьому задіяно ці люди неймовірні Вони
круті натхненні вони все хочуть зробити
для того щоб допомогти малозабезпеченим
людям ну мабуть все-таки так підготовка
тому щоце жту ту відбувається Люди
навіть не втомлюються тому що на емоціях
на адреналіні на позитивній ноті все це
робиться і люди не втомлюються просто
Класно
Класно дякую бачите справа громад
благодійник тобто не просто а от отак
тому долучайтесь до справи громад будьте
нашими благодійниками знову ж таки прошу
модераторів скинути реквізити або
посилання в коментарі або обов'язково це
буде прикріплено під відео там де опис
до відео ви побачите там всі реквізити
щоби долучитись і знову ж таки стати
благодійником як як Павло як
Павло а ще поставили тут досить цікаву
камеру маленьку таку яка буде записувати
Весь процес І от зараз якраз її
перевіряє відеооператор і буде записаний
Весь процес і потім в
прискореному
випадку в прискореній швидкості буде
видно
як дуже-дуже швидко тут зникають
продукти і робляться з них готові
набори Тобто це буду набори ще і з
позитивним настроєм набори будуть ще із
позитивним настроєм бачите обов'язково
це одна із обов'язкових умов щоби був
позитивний настрій тому що А як
по-іншому працювати знаєте воно якось
коли такі важкі умови
коронавірус якось так все дуже сумно і
да і ситуація в країні невесела плюс ще
там на кордоні стягують війська якось
воно все так нагнітає нагнітає але ось
то скотчем робить отак вжух вжух вжух
вжух скажи як користуватись зараз я
прийду до
тебе оцією суперштукою все дуже просто
ставляємо скотч продеваємо його сюди
зажимаємо і працюємо і воно готово так
так класно а втомлюєшся Якось це робити
фізично Бо мені здається що найважче -
це скотч
Ні ну тут Вся робота вона важка Я вважаю
кожна робота має
свої свою важкість Ви оце звуком робити
Отак найважче для всіх звук як його
витерти Це
точно готуємось до роботи
Дякую там є то вона розкаже про
100 Тонічка голова правління справи
громад Розкажіть будь ласка скільки нам
ще потрібно коштів для повного щастя ну
дивіться дал Бог Як то кажуть і люди
добрі конвербивається конр
Ми забрали зараз 2000 грн ой 2000
наборів
Пардон 2000 наборів які сьогодні уїдуть
всі вже можна офіційно сказати в Одеську
область Одеська область нам теж дуже
допомогла Наступного тижня ми плануємо 5
ся продуктових наборів і нам ще потрібно
зібрати десь 350 000 грн Ну плюс-мінус
ось тобто у нас частково гроші вже є ми
вже почали збирати проплачувати рахунки
на наступний конвеєр на 5 000
продуктових благодійних наборів але як
завжди нам трошечки не вистачає тому
дуже-дуже просимо ми не зупиняємося в
своєму бажанні допомагати людям ну це
люди прихилого віку це багатодітні сім'ї
тощо їм дуже потріб поріб допомога я
Нагадую що одна коробочка це місяць
харчів у наприклад якоїсь бабусі Тобто
ви маленькою коробочку
250 грвен яка коштує можете допомогти
цілий
місяць бути не бути голодною якоїсь
бабусі десь якоїсь області якось так
Дякую сюди гроші збирає Ну Це дуже
маленьке
Андрій шуткує що Соня туди гроші збирає
в
сумочку зараз ви побачите як
запускається конвеєр і почнеться Дуже
шумно Оце те що ми скаржимось на скотч
Ми якраз обрали такий момент
щоби не було шуму щоби спокійно вам все
розказати а зараз доведеться кричати
тому що не буде чутно пшли покажемо
спочатку як воно
буде
зараз Віталій гайдукевич вімкне музику і
якщо стрімпаде тикажи людям зараз буде
ввімкнена музика і є вірогідність того
що стрім ютубчик нам покладе але ми
будемо намагатись Якось це виправити але
без без музики неможливопрац але без
музики неможливо працювати так веселіше
ось Тут подають коробки на
конвеєр окремі люди подають їх бачите
вони починають свій шлях Також тут
завантажують в них найперше це борошно
воно в принципі найважче серед усіх тут
упаковок Я так зрозуміла що крупи там по
900 можливо грам борошна тут кілограм
тобто воно чи скільки щоб я не
помилилась во ну кілограм звісно воно
висотою як я це точно і це ще запакували
скільки вже вже більше там 400 наборів
запакували уявіть скільки тут яка була
гора тому ось його ще подають сюди на
стрічкур Напишіть будь ласка чи чути
оцініть від одного до 10ти звук і від
одного до 10ти картинку 1010 це значить
все класно все чутно бо
можливо технічні нюанси звук там
відео
тому звертаю вашу увагу всі ма всі в
рукавичках ось тут цілі набори лежать
бачите для всіх бажаючих ось маски тобто
все І ось маски і ще раз можна
попирскати антисептиком Я вже пирскала
але можна ще
раз
антисептик руки обробила ще раз
антисептиком
і ось власне тут вони ставлять її на
стрічку
подають
Я пам'ятаю от як Віталій
розповідав що були негативні досвіди і з
тим що приїжджали наприклад до людей
дійсно розповідали волонтери що
приїжджають а там ну реально відкриває
людина з Айфоном і каже що давай давай
занось сюди набір але я пам'ятаю ще і я
зніму на вулиці маску трошки подихаю але
пам'ятаю ще і позитивні досвіди із цим
тому що коли ми приїздили
до людини а там відкриває двері
старенькі дідусь і каже Дякую І ти
Знаєте тут не так важливий сам набір
якби там що в ньому як в принципі те що
цей дідусь відчуває себе комусь
потрібним
тобто він такий видно що Одинокий і так
ну заглядаєш квартира така трошки
документи вам які показати документи
Пам'ятаєш він каже був був так каже каже
розкажи людина каже
дідусь дідусь каже Які документи вам
дати Ми кажемо Та не треба нам документи
він каже а як же ж ну типу я от дивись
там в мене паспорт там він каже Я не
знаю що і він такий розгублений типу що
ми кажемо Та нічого не треба тримайте
Він дуже дякую бо каже я зайвий раз
боюся виходити в магазин бо Ну звичайно
що ее група риску да ризику і
він розуміється що Ну що робити
вакцинації Нема сьогодні вже рік
пройшов з того конвеєра який був квітні
в квітні того року вже пройшов рік Що Що
зробила влада це повинна робити влада це
такі конвеєри адресну допомогу
ее потрібно робити вакцинацію в країні
щоб такого не було щоб не було потреби в
людей для цього А в нас зараз як
виходить карантин зрозуміло з яких
причин зрозуміло з яких причин локдаун
але що робити людям в яких просто нема
грошей Ну підприємці які не працюю не
працюють тому що локдаун вони не
отримують гроші вони не отримують
прибутку Влада каже ну по 8 000 грн
можливо ви отримаєте десь там вони ще за
попередній локдаун виплатили майже
третину від тих людей які подали
[музика]
е заявки ці на цю допомогу вони платили
третину ще дві третини вони не виплатили
за попередній локдаун вже почався новий
звідки брати гроші що робити людям
відповіді немає як Степанов каже нам
треба було пять років тому да робити Ну
можливо два роки тому треба було якось
голосувати інакше Можливо так би воно
було б ну Наразі я так думаю що якщо б
все пішло трошки по іншому сценарію то
можливо і не потрібно було б сьогодні
робити такі конвеєри оце дуже важлива
думка Я вважаю що люди які це отримують
це найважливіше це не не та крупа і там
я не знаю там та
тушонка чи там яка згущонка Вони
отримують
е важливіше
за ту крупу Вони отримують якусь
впевненість що вони не самі що є хтось
хто
потурбується про них що є люди якісь там
волонтери що є якісь організації які про
це думають розумієте бо на владу
сьогодні Ну майже немає жодної Надії
Майже жодної Надії немає а ту от Отак би
щоб було б наприклад би написано було б
з команда і вони були брендовані да і в
команда сказала Ми вже відправили 24
мльни там таких продуктових наборів ну
зрозу
зрозуміло що якщо вони так це зробили
давайте змагатися в ому це офіс
європейської солідарності і він
відправляє тисячі таких наборів а офіс
партії з там слуга народу що вони
сьогодні роблять нічого вони там вілюр
мабуть що просто десь не знаю там
подземний ход якийсь вони там зробили до
влюра десь там вони трошки відпочивають
бо що я не бачу ну Чим вони займаються
ну Чим вони займаються чим займається
Рада національної безпеки та оборони
хіба не цим треба займатися хіба не
треба Займатися тим що в нас ну
величезна небезпека
від дій Росії Яка стягнула ці війська до
кордону вони щось таке там
Ну вони думаєш йлки-палки
нущо вітаю І
запрошую бют запрошую партію слуга
народа запрошую хто там в нас ще голос і
всі інші партії вони вони ні це не вони
в своїх офісах робити те саме що роби
європейська Солідарність вже другий рік
поспіль допомагає людям у складній
ситуації всі знають зараз що на всіх є
можливість ходити на роботу о скільки
локдаун в багатьох областях України і це
говорить про те що у людей якщо на
початку чи Минулого року ще якісь
збереження були то зараз їх дуже-дуже
мало тому людям необхідна допомога
майтесь допомогою не балобольством не як
там вчора на брифінгу дивився у Парижі
ніби немає в нього у Зеленського немає
нежиттю але він стоїть краще не на
тратити кошти а на допомогу людям і все
буде добре А знаєш що хотів запитати ще
ми питали в Віталія гайдукевича І я так
вважаю що ми якщо буде Петро Олексійович
також запитаємо чи от цій конвеєр який
через рік і він повторюється чи це не є
наслідком саме
ще друга друга річниця да двох рочків
Зеленського оце є насчно символічно
символічний наслідок
економічної роботи президента його
команди тут же ж унікально він
відповідає за все абсолютно зараз ні
жоден президент не мав таку
відповідальності як зараз Зеленський
якби були там коаліції там різні партії
призначали різних Міністрів а тут
абсолютно за все відповідає одна людина
Зеленський все ну просто він на своє
своїм ім'ям привів дуже багато людей які
відповідають за економіку за соціальну
політику за все інше свій уряд і в нього
Свій парламент Да він своїм ім'ям їм їх
якби завів все він несе за них
відповідальність абсолютно Ось ця
відповідальність Ну хто відповідальний
ви бачите вже другий рі рік поспіль А
хто безвідповідальний Я думаю тут
пояснювати А чим вони займаються
сьогодні а от чим займаються сьогодні
слуги народу та інші депутати і політич
ти ще не бачив там накупили машин собі
нових треба обкатать же ж правда бачили
це цілий список там Мерседеси різні
машини треба їхти мама любит скорость
папа любит скорость бабушка
любидукатувать що що ще треба робити
Треба напевно поїхати відпочити як
арахамія да пам'ятаєш за Мальдіви як
вони да Треба поїхати на Мальдіви на
Сейшели туди-сюди а ЄС депутат ЄС я
депутат Київради ЄС вони чим займаються
во пакують коробки і допомагають людям
як в 14-му році допомагали збройним
силам все Ну вот пан Зеленський говорить
Байден треба зробити більше я нещодавно
робив список що за останній період
зробив Зеленський А що зробив Байден і
виходить Ну просто для себе подивитись і
виходить що Зеленський крім розмов
нічого більше не робить а Байден вводить
санкції підвищує он вчора конгрес
проголосував збільшити допомогу Україні
на 150 млн доларів Ну це конкретна
робота реально чому Байден не робить
такі конвеєри А де Зеленський Чому ти не
зупинив реформу забезпечення службовим
житлом в Збройних Силах Чому ти
зупинив реформування системи харчування
в Збройних Силах і вона погіршилась
суттєво зараз на що скаржаться і
військові на що скаржаться і депутати в
комітеті по обороні нещодавно був звіт
нещодавно
звітували що ну Чим ти займаєшся Ти
навіть не те що просто зупинив Ти просто
вже процес руйнації пішов вниз в
Збройних силах України Чим він
займається ну з'їздив ти на фронт
пофоткався в недолугому свому
броніжилеті й carр який незрозуміло хто
тобі дав навіть нефтон ходиш без шеврону
хоча б Прапора України ти блін верховний
головнокомандувач а він і герба ніколи
не і герба і герба не одягає як
відрізніти від врізняти До речі да це
вже два роки давайте трошки Як
відрізняти Голобородька З того серіалу
від Зеленського Голобородько завжди в
серіалу був значок з гербо украї лопці
Вже кличуть треба грузити фуру далі
продуктами так що гарного всім дня У вас
є кому вас захищати це європейська
Солідарність і це ком'юніті людей які
збираються тут і партійці і безпартійні
вони завжди коли складно збираються для
того щоб допомогти людям і своїй державі
Слава нації Україна обов'язково
[музика]
переможе Пішли ще
покаже Зараз зараз я одягну
маску на вулиці подхали Тепер можна
маску
одягати ось
тут чи цеє петличка А ось тут вже готові
набори бачите
складають таку
пірамідку тут палети ну така знаєте
чоловіча важка робота Чесно
кажучи і їх вивозять запитай каже Зараз
прийдуть слуги народу допомагати сказали
треба сказати що будуть люди відповідати
ти таке я я запитаю Зараз запитаю на
секунду запитаю
кажуть слуги народу приїдуть допомагати
да слуги нах
дождшься от них дождшься Ні не вірять
люди
каже от них
дождшься просто показав я ще покажу
покажу ще конвеєр як працює а я отак от
якось зачеплю зараз А я не зачеплю вона
не
заче
[музика]
стосовно людей які сьогодні тут присутні
це все найактивніші волонтери справи
громад з якими ми постійно на зв'язку і
якби тут просто Київська частина
волонтерів справи громад які от з нами
вже не перше вони це роблять
тут за музику за музику відповідає
завжди Віталій гайдукевич в нього гарний
смак Він знає що треба вмикати коли
люди працюють і коли люди відпочивають
чи треба вмикати це різна музика
буде А тут сміття
складають це все
сміття просто це офіс і якби ці
приміщення м'яко кажучи не не для того
щоб робити такі
конвеєри це офісне приміщення звичайне
Тобто там кабінети а тут вони якось
примудрились створити конвеєр ось тут
заклали плівкою хоч якось щоби захистити
офісне покриття ніхто не міг подумати що
в офісі ЄС взагалі можливо
таке
[музика]
біля цієї стіни вже нема
коробок
а коробки а коробки а короб
де все коробок нема Треба нові робити
ось ще вони
пішли запитаємо лини що відбувається бо
люди які приходять не знають що
відбувається
[музика]
що відбувається люди які приходять в
стрім вони не знають що відбувається
розкажидиться Сьогодні знову зібралися
Шалені
бджілки ці Шалені бджілки збирають
допомогу зараз для тих кому зараз важко
що це означає наскільки я пам'ятаю В 12
областях в нас зараз локдаун да червона
зона це всі пенсіонери Це ті люди які з
групи ризику Вони реально сигналізують
весь час в ЄС в справу громад про те що
вони не можуть навіть з елементарними
речима вийти за продуктами да Тобто їм
ну фізично немає чого поїсти навіть тому
сьогодні волонтери і в тому числі ви да
глядачі YouTube каналу ЄС зібрали кошти
на те щоби оце все тут з'явилося в офісі
ЄС І сьогодні тут пакують тут є борошно
цукор Ну якась ще крупа я не пам'ятаю
вже яка олія золота Да яка зараз скільки
там 70 грнь за літр і всі жартують про
те що Аннушка вже розли
масло от тому дешевше було б ананаси
покласти навіть дешевше дешевше але на
ананасах на жаль не посмажиш нічого от
тому все-таки олія тому що це важливіше
це продукти першої
необхідності і Ну я так сподіваюся що це
не останній конвеєр Наскільки я розумію
заявлено понад 10 000 пакунків Вони
поїдуть в різні області і люди ви будь
ласка долучайтесь так само ми не можемо
всіх запросити на конвеєр тому що
все-таки антиковідні заходи Да ми не
можемо багато людей тут збирати але ви
можете за реквізитами які бачите в описі
під відео відправити скільки можете
грошей тому що конвеєр буде тривати і і
всі наступні тижні поки це буде
необхідно ви так само можете поширювати
це відео підписуватися на YouTube бути
активними Да і ми
переможемо
баки
яляти за
щоре колюяни мої голоди людей не буде А
ми за поіве як потреба стане похоі А
вські баяри ла
нашана
[музика]
ко буде
буде
[музика]
люди знову питають вчати куди можна
отримати таку допомогу
це треба розказати партійні потрібно
звертатись до Дивіться ви зараз
проживаєте в якійсь області
у кожної області у європейської
солідарності є партійний осередок
Заходите в Google і пишете партійний
осередок ЄС або там наприклад просто ЄС
Там припустимо Харківська область і вам
видасть навіть адресу реквізити контакти
Все вам видасть туди звертатись туди
писати дзвонити туди Ось так місцеві
депута вони просто за це відповідальні
так тобто наше завдання збирати Кошти я
маю на увазі наше Як справи громад бо я
просто справа громад наше завдання
збирати кошти на цей проект щоби
закуповувати продукти потім все це
пакувати робити набори а завдання
партійних організацій займатись
власне розповсюдженням цих наборів У них
є списки у них вони якби цим займаються
тому за це вже відповідає ЄС бо це
Спільний проект європейської
солідарності справи громад десь була
наліпка хотіла
показати на кожній коробці є наліпка там
написано що це Спільний проект тому одні
відповідають за одне інші за інше тому
звертайтесь до місцевих ваших
організацій вони формують списки
збирають І якщо все буде добре якщо ми
будемо збирати більше коштів то ми
зможемо виготовити більше продуктових
наборів І власне вам дістанеться
обов'язково теж
тут запитаю валенки чи вірить вона
вірить вона в те що слуги народу
прийдуть на
допомогу
Олена кажуть що слюги народу прийдуть на
допомогу так приду прийдуть прийдуть я
вам хочу сказати що ми Ми сподівалися що
ми цього року вже не будемо цього робити
але це дуже Такі приємні
турботи Добре добре дуже приємні турботи
Але краще б цього б не відбувалося ну
кажуть що хороша ложка до обіду у нас
тепер є новий прилад Ми думали що його
не буде ну він не буде потрібен але
Ну на жаль звідки
таізкажи тут знаходиться хлопець який
його
зробивкидаю добре він займається
професійно професійною дизайнерською
дизайнерськими меблями і його звуть Саша
ккравецький Він знаходиться у нас на
початку конвеєра от в чорній без Давай
його сюдивай Давай його сюди Ми
зараз візьмемо інтерв'ю коротеньке тієї
людині яка зробила оцю штуку це конве
завдяки цьому можна вже збирати скоро
буде автівки будемо тут як Ford зробив
той
конвеєр Вітаю Олександр Розкажіть що це
таке і звідки воно
взялося З самого початку ми коли
покупали ці коробки то було дуже важко і
стояло багато штовхачів які штовхали ці
коробки зараз це було близько 60 кг я
вирішив подумати як це покращити і на
цьму
виробництві зробили ось такий конверт
тепер коробка Іде за од-д секунди От і
все ми Жартуємо що вже скоро будемо як
Форд збирати тут машини Все можливо Чому
б ні запорожців не роблять Чому б не
зробити свой електрокар це можливо
кажуть що слуги народу прийдуть на
допомогу вірите чи ні Ну поки що вони
нічом не допомогли чому зараз має
допомагати Хоча я чим депутати слух
народу сьогодні займаються як вважаєте
Ну хтось когось викликає хтось комусь
телефонує хтось з кимось переписується
Можливо там десь відпочивають на
Мальдівах чи в Єгипті тому інших
варіантів поки немає два роки Зеленський
президент які наслідки ну наслідки
десятки тисяч загиблих е в Україні від
коронавірусу загиблі на сході України
АА падіння економіки е погіршення
міжнародної міжнародних коаліції в
зв'язку України з міжнародною коаліцією
а з гарних наслідків Ну треба подумати
поки я не
знаходжу ніхто не знаходить як це може
бути таке Я не знаю Ну хтось же
знаходить там Можливо в його партії но
здравомислячі люди не знаходять і цей
конвеєр це є також наслідок роботи
Зеленського ну це о якщо Ну це ж влада
повинна цим займатися не волонтери
повинна займатися Влада Але зазвичай все
тримається на волонтерах і на людях які
люблять цю країну От і все дякую дякує
вам дякує від всіх глядачів дякую дякую
на волонтерах ітримається вся країна Ось
і все я покажу
[музика]
конвеєр
а то ви бачите є ще не тільки той хто
ліпить скотч А є ще той хто складає
коробку бо я не бачила да це так важко
бо вона коробка вона гостра ну її треба
заламати ру руки завжди руки всі е той в
ранах тому рукавички ті що
для Будівельників тобто вони більш субкі
і не ранять руки бо я теж десь оце
поранила собі десь дивилась коробку он
здерла шматок шкіри не дуже така приємна
штука А ще знаєте класно оці такі як у
художників або тих хто там ліпить з
глини у них такі нарукавники є
спеціальні схоже як у мене кофта але
нарукавники такі і от я бачила що
одягали або таки як варіант одягали люди
на рукавники щоби не
не різати оцю частину бо коли закладаєш
щось в коробку то тут може рука просто
випадково зачепитись і це не дуже
приємна така
штука дай я покажу що прикольно ще
потримай це такий прикольний зал то
називається акваріум А це називається
Колізей колозей Да і бачите оце
європейська Солідарність тут це можна
перенести Вона така перенеситься і от
Саме тут тут ви бачили вже багато
стрімів відео фото звітів от Саме тут
сюди приїжджають кислородні
концентратори саме саме тут були були
тут костюми для медичних працівників які
того року приїжджали із Китаю
із Кореї тут приходить і тут саме тут
відбувається
конвеєр запаковують продуктові набори що
ще тут щось ще щось привозили я вже не
пам'ятаю що що тут ще було
ее якісь ліки ми привозили ще от Саме
тут все відбувається це офіс
європейської солідарності взагалі-то тут
працюють люди тут є тут збори Якщо треба
я збиратися тут є екран Да Де можна там
щось там подивитися якісь презентації
тут люди працюють Взагалі І тут отам от
кабінети там кабінету це відкритий офіс
він такий бачите з прозорими стінами це
офіс європейської солідарності
як виглядає офіс європейської
солідарності знають багато людей а я
хотів би подивитися як виглядає офіс
слуги народу яки там офіс голосу як вони
виглядають Що там Що там взагалі
відбувається в них чи там є люди чи вони
там щось працюють чим вони тим
займаються Я не знаю
чи може там той офіс він в вілюр чи як
де де вони там де працюють кальянчик
вони там курять от я хов хотів би там
подивитись чи можна туди прийти зайти чи
поспілкуватися з ними просто подивитись
чим вони там займаються що вони там
роблять тут все зрозуміло що тут
незрозумілого О бачите воно тихіше все
стало так типу вжух і
тихо пішли подивимось що що
відбувається закладуваєм продукти по
максимуму Чому Тому що поки перерва
треба накласти бачити ціці продукти да
на стіл бо щоб во ї вже що пряма робота
покажи треба сплітки і діставати окрема
робота - це діставати їх з плівки бо
воно ж коли приходить партія продуктів
воно все запаковане Бачите тут є
ножичик тут є Святослав
Бойко до якого ми зараз звернемося він
робить те що він розпаковує оці баночки
згущенки і
подає Він ріже просто Він ріже просто
привіт я як маленьке звірятку яке
загортає шоколад у фольгу але я Ніхера
не загортаю шоколад у фольгу Я ріжу цю
клійонку е-е короче цее кайфова
можливість попрацювати на благо людей АА
Чесно кажучи потрапити сюди на цей
конвеєр було надзвичайно важко
А мені довелося представити свою довідку
що в мене антитіла що я Вже перехворів
ковідом і це збільшило мої шанси на
фізичну участь у
конвеєрі сказати що я втомлений це
взагалі про це навіть згадувати не
потрібно це може бути навіть приємно в
це кайфово це класно коли ти є Коли ти
робиш корисну справу для людей коли ти
працюєш на благо своєї країни коли ти
працюєш в колі однодумців це навпаки
додає сили додає сили додає наснаги і
вперед класно У тебе є ностальгія за
минулим роком бо ти тут на Минулого року
теж провів багато часу від початку і до
кінця фактично коли звичайно що я дуже
хотів потрапити на цей конвеєр тому тому
що Я заскучив засумував за відчуттям
отої єдиної справи коли збирається
однодумці і роблять добру справу Це
відчуття єдиної справи
відчуття приналежності до єдиного
правильного організму воно викликає
ностальгію воно викликає залежність
своєрідну і взагалі можливість
допомагати іншим то є наркотик скоро два
рочки як Зеленський президент Як ти
вважаєш отакий конвеєр - це класний
результат його діяльності чи на
превеликий жаль це не результат а швидше
такий наслідок його
діяльності це не це це власне Не не
результат я би був щасливий якби цього
конваєра не
було я був би надзвичайно радий І
дякував богові і правлінням що і
правлінню що цього конвеєра би не було
але ми виходимо з того що ми
маємо Я не є прихильником диванної зради
диванного диванної експертної думки
тому
виходячи з того що ми маємо в країні
повну
Ми намагаємося якось цю цю
зменшити І так я я так розумію що нам
треба
перетосуватися Так
Так нам треба нам треба докласти
максимальних зусиль так для зменшення
оцього гузна В яке ми
потрапили
і я тішуся що власне маю таку нагоду
докластися до цього якщо країну
заполонила Зелена Чума і гниль значить
це треба прибирати і якщо не прибирати
поступово то на кінець каденції оцієї
зеленої гнилі набереться дуже багато
роботи дуже багато дуже великий об'єм
прибирання набереться тому ми потрошки
потрошки потрошки прибираємо наслідки
крокування зеленої плісневи по території
України
і Я дуже надіюся дуже надіюся що
власне оця задниця в яку ми потрапили
Вона хоч трошки чомусь людей і навчить я
пам'ятаю як минулого року ви робили
переклад пісні про карантин і ми робили
тоді ще відосік з конвеєра про карантин
було дуже
прикольно Це було класно це було весело
і тоді здавалося що це все ненадовго Що
це Що це все От Швидко мине а зараз ми
вже бачимо 20-й рік минув воно а
ситуація ця вона ніяк не минає вона
нікуди не дівається і навіть не має
відчуття що воно от ОТТ закінчиться
абсолютно ну тобто відчуття що це ще
надовго Ну я скажімо як
музикант я можу впевнено сказати що від
карантинів від локдаунів я страдаю
страждаю чи не найбільше Тому що моя
робота пов'язана з масовими заходами де
велике зібрання людей
а я на початку 20-го року власне в
лютому Я думаю що це буквально на
два-три місяці і все вляжеться Вже
почався 21й рік вже ми доходимо десь до
Екватора 21-го року і я розумію що це
таки надовго це може бути і до кінця
21-го року і до середини 22-го року лише
питання в тім як влада буде адаптуватися
до нових умов як які рішення будуть
прийматися ну наразі те що ми бачимо це
є повне Як каже Петро Олексійович повне
дилетантство і я з ним погоджуюсь на всі
100%. знаєш ти як музикант А я як Слухач
вже скучила за концертами за якимось
проводженням часу десь не вдома А отут
от навіть навіть Отут на конвеєрі У мене
теж є Антитіла і тут у багатьох вже хто
перекворів ковідом то тут є хоч якась
можливість вийти в люди знаєте бо зараз
із карантином Ну просто і в Києві ще
продовжили локдаун аж до травня місяця
продовжили до 30 квітня но його
продовжать і до 10 травня Я переконаний
в цьому 2 травня якраз припадає
Великдень
і я думаю
що в рамках проведення
антиепідеміологічних заходів власне буде
продовжений карантин Можливо він буде
продовжений і до кінця травня у нас 11
квітня мав бути концерт в докері
Київському на Оболоні І ми його
перенесли на 24
травня і сподіваєтесь що Ну я вже ні на
що не Сподіваюся Я вже ні на що не
Надіюся е Я просто живу фактично
сьогоднішнім днем я розумію що в
будь-який час все може змінитися в
будь-який момент все що ти напланував
воно може зруйнуватися тому щоб не не
розстроюватись тому щоб не не падати
духом зайвий раз Я просто нічого вже
собі на наперед глобального не планую я
в 19-му році в 19-му ще купила квитки на
bлі Talent група з штатів і у них
Концерт мав бути 20-го року в квітні
його перенесли на рік вперед але я так
розумію що ніякого концерту взагалі не
буде І мені написали ці партер.ua чи хто
там вони концерt.ua що типу мовляв
переноситься концерт хто зна на коли
тому згоріли і грошики і квиточки я так
розумію все наві чи можна купити квитки
і чи яка інформація Оста Я хочу запитати
так чи можна купити квитки і чи звичайно
звичайно можна на сайті докера можна на
сайті
здаєтьсяра Карабас на на Карабас можна
купити
квиточки звісно треба розуміти що
купуючи квитки ви йдете на певний ризик
Я не кажу про ризик втрати своїх коштів
а про ризик того що концерт буде
перенесений це є зараз в теперішній час
цілком такі закономірні ризики але
концерт буде ось він
Я дуже надіюся Я дуже надіюсь якщо мені
знов же відмінять концерт 24 травня
Тобто перенесуть його чи то 27 травня
Боже я я я мушу подивитися на на яке
число в мене концерт Зараз я скажу гурт
Широкий Лан так ГУР Широкий
Лан 27 травня Перепрошую 27 травня це
четвер буде 27 травня Отже якщо хто має
бажання Приєднуйтесь 27 травня в
Київському докір на Оболоні буде сольний
концерт гурту Широкий Лан з презентацію
альбому мантра юху А якщо ми не зможемо
це зробити тоді е ми назвемо акцію
Антитіла концерт
ее без всякої оглядки на гурт Антитіла
Ми просто називаємо антитільний концерт
і проведемо його тут для своїх це буде
концерт для своїх і входом на концерт
буде довідка про наявність антитіл так
що хворійте хворійте здобувайте антитіла
і Приходьте на наш концерт класно будемо
чекати біжи біжи біжи класно треба
запитатиє концерти
гліби вітаємо Привіт
Hell говорили щойно зі святом про
концерт його гурту він каже там 27
травня незрозуміло буде чи не буде А
козаксстим теж переносять концерти через
ковід звісно звісно козакчистм
переносять концерти тому що взагалі
незрозуміло колице відбувається і
організації які планують ці
заходи деякі взагалі відміли відмінили
концерти і справа не в єдиному концерті
А справа в серії концертів у турі які
можуть відбуватися тільки при
зрозумілому графіку Бо велика кількість
людей у багатьох городах купують білети
перенесени навіть
фестивалі які відбувалися от зараз буде
травень починаючи з травня починають
відбуватися фестивалі великі всій
Україні і на лідируючих фестивалях на
багатьох козаксм теж приймає участь але
що в цьому році буде з цими фестивалями
фестивалями поки не зрозуміло ну
Минулого року я так розумію взагалі
ніяких фестивалей не було я такого не
пам'ятаю Ну так Минулого року були
спроби перевести це в
онлайн були зйомки гуртів у
фестивальному режимі на
майданчиках е це цікаво але ну це
потребує дуже великого економічного
якогось е вкладення тому що ну на якісь
гроші це потрібно робити і все одно люди
як як коли вживу приходять на фестиваль
вони відчувають дух вони відчувають
драйв і цього телевізором на жаль не не
заміниш ніяк Як справи з своєю книгою
розкажи ее з книгою добре
книгу На жаль зараз ізза локдауну Ми не
можемо продовжити поїздки з презентацією
книги по Україні на
жаль але ми плануємо замість цього може
на на наступному тижнію може через
тиждень фронтовий
тур в нас є вже домовленості з
декількома
підрозділами там це не презентація книги
ми її адаптували
виставу спеціально для військових
ми це зробимо А
так з продажами книг з розповсюдженням
книг Я так як у всіх локдауні це не
[музика]
нетре прорекламуй книгу Бо у нас стрм
дивля все дуже
просто набираєте у пошуковому
видавництво білка дуже Просто білочка
така орешки гризе заходити або в
пошуковому Вику або прямо в Фейсбуці і
потрапляєте
на сторінку видавництва Білка і там на
цій сторінці там не дуже глибоко моя
книга просто вам треба поставити плюсик
у коментарях і видавництво з вами
зв'яжеться Як називається книга Гліб
бабіч вірші та пісні шукаєте видавництво
білка Гліб бабіч вірші та пісні і
знайдете книгу Гліба яка дуже прекрасна
Дякую глібе за коментар дкую запита д
роки Зеленського а два роки Зеленського
давай все так стоп я тебе нікуди не
відпускаю назад Як ти вважаєш класний
наслідок роботи двох років Зеленського
такі конвеєри Йому ж вже два рочки майже
скоро розумієш якщо б це було принаймні
яко на якоїсь площині Да не гірше або
Трохи краще але ми з кожним місяцем цих
двох років пробиваємо все нове і нове
дно це ми робили В тому році і це повто
в цьому краще не стало гірше стало самою
епідемією два роки тому вони зібрали
величезний величезні гроші величезні на
ці гроші можна було створити власну
вакцину організувати центр який створює
вакцину закупити сотні мобільних
шпиталів обладнаних
так навчити людей забезпечити
кісним сотні лікарень купити тисячі
концентраторів яких зараз не не
вистачає замість цього ці гроші закатали
в асфальт і попутно трохи розсували по
карманам са насправді не трохи
і ми зараз прийшли ми мали рік кредиту
по часу ми мали величезні гроші держава
Я маю на увазі і це все було знищено
знищено і смерті зараз і муки людей від
ковіду вони цілком на совісті цієї
клоунської банди і прийде час коли все
це згадають і за все це доведеться
відповісти тому що ну продукти Ладно я і
ніхто ніхто і не не не думав що у них
дайде навіть думка про це буде А щодо
тих же концентраторів це ж ну верхівка
айсбергу точно так же і ми разом з
фондом Порошенка розвозимо по країні
концентратори а і тільки зараз вони
задумались про
те щоб купити вони там велику кількість
ще і за завищеною ціною Це Це взагалі Ми
там виходить так ми купуємо
концентратор десь
за ну біля 25 000 вони купили за 34 000
але при тої кількості такий концентратор
стоїть коштує 20 20 000 Це пряма
поставка з Китаю тобто 14 000 маржі вони
не втримались туди туди
закласти Ви питали розповідали про
колись про заробоіток на крові на
смертях дивиться Оце він оце він і коли
відкриється це після того як ну вони
зникнуть Я думаю що я не знаю наскільки
І на
що вистачить на пожиттєві строки і це не
ті розказні що е навесні будемо саджати
два роки Вони мають свої суди
прокуратури е дбр все
ее це не те що про Порошенко розповідали
виявилося що нічого нема тому що все
лежить на поверхні і тому коли вони
підуть теж все буде лежати на поверхні і
асфальт і ковід і люди які задихнулися
без кисню
і фокуси з
тестуванням тільки завдяки тому що ми в
10 разів робимо менше тестування ніж в
Європі ми тримаємося десь на рівні
третього місця хотя по рівню
вакцинування на нас вакцинування нас вже
обігнав давно Гондурас і ми на
останньому місці якщо б ми тестувались
як Європа ми б давно і сильно були на
першому місці якщо б реєстрували всіх
хто помер звісно від хо від ковіда ми
були на першому місці ми в жахливої
ситуації а Влада маніпулюває все що вона
може це тільки маніпулювати і оцим
маніпулюванням Влада
приховує Наскільки в нас важка картина
Ну ми чинимо спротив оце все спротив
концентратори спротив це спротив
наслідкам недолугості чинної
влади А я знаєш як думаю я думаю що якщо
концентратори коштують там по 35 по 36
то це скільки вкрали половину 18 18
Ні ми тільки що прорахували це 14 000
які незрозуміло чому це саме ті
концентратори розумієш якщо Петро
Олексійович вітаю добй вітаю вітаю
Добрий день ми тут от так трошки
змінююсь обговорюємо якраз концентратори
кисневі те що вони заку по таким цінам І
взагалі те що д роки Зеленського привели
до того що у нас знову конвеєр хто міг
про таке взагалі
подумати наш конвеєр Це точно не
залежить від Зеленського це благодійна
ініціатива яка свого часу починалася
волонтерами в 14му році і просто коло
людей які не залишаються байдужими до
проблем будь-якої людини але і те що на
сьогоднішній день десятки тисяч звернень
до єпейської Солідарності до справи
громад до наших ветеранських і
волонтерських організацій це означає що
ми поруч і точно Будемо допомагати людям
не залишивши їх без захисту і без
допомоги це позиція номер один а позиція
номер два - це тоді коли хтось на біді
людській заробляє собі на кишеню і тоді
коли наша організація зараз купує
концентратори по 27 26 25 000 де
знайдемо і коли нам пропонують в Китаї
якби нам було можливість і потреба
привезти 50 000 їх можна купити було би
по 15-17 000 ці злочинці знову
заробляють на смертях і ставлять на по
той інформації що ми маємо ціни 34 35 36
37 000 грн отримуючи да вдвічі
підвищуючи ціни і безумовно ми не
залишимося остронь безумовно ми
вимагаємо щоби ті хто заробляє так
опинилася за гратами А гроші були
повернуті бо для людей це вже не питання
їжі для людей це питання право жити
право дихати І сьогодні ми маємо
забезпечити не тільки лікарні інфекційні
лікарні дитячі лікарні Сьогодні
концентратори мають бути в кожного
сімейного лікаря Бо людина приходить
йому не вистачає кисню тоді коли в вже
пішов до доктора це має бути в кожній
амбулаторії і сьогодні наша друга хвиля
ми вже розвозимо по амбулаторіям по
сімейним лікарям Вчора ми повернулися з
Черкас де ми мали неймовірну фантастичну
зустріч з лікарями яких намагалися не
пустити до нас до зустріч головні лікарі
з районів Черкаської області приїхали до
нас до зустріч обговорювати антиковідний
план А завершилося це абсолютно е
дивними дзвінками з посиланням на офіс
президента наполегливо не радячи їхати
на зустріч з європейською солідарностю і
дуже важливо що лікарі їх післали три
чорти і дуже важливо що лікар а на
сьогоднішній день разом з воїном
збройних сил це найбільш поважна
особистість в державі і тому я би просив
і вас Марію і вас Андрію і всіх блогерів
і всіх журналістів обов'язково кожен
день находити сюжети і дякувати лікарям
розповідати про героя лікаря про героя
медичного працівника про героя медичну
сестру яку в Черкасах Нам повідомили що
рівень заробітної плати старшої
медсестри яка працює
24х7 складає 6 000 грн і ся пвтори
доплата за ковідме і це кажуть головні
лікарі це кажуть медики це не те що
хтось
намагається зробити на цього
Хай безумовно ми вимагаємо ви обіцяли
підвищити в три три рази 300% дати
доплати ми провели це рішення не
доплатите будете звільнені Це я вам
обіцяю ви обіцяли що лікарі будуть
застраховані в нас сьогодні є просто ну
жахливі приклади коли родина втратила
лікаря Чи медичного працівника і Вже
третій місяць ходять по паперам для того
щоби отримати страхову виплату за втрату
лікаря який загинув від ковіду і Якщо у
нас на сьогоднішній день більше
400 випадків страхових випадків коли
держава мала виплатити А виплачили як
мені повідомили
86 що зараз думає про державу члени
родини лікаря я або медичного працівника
який загинув який третій місяць вони не
можуть найти кошти для того щоб
поховатись і безумовно що це є ще більш
обурливе
ніж кісневі концентратори але на
сьогоднішній день ми про добро ми про
хороше ми про захист ми про допомогу ми
про те що
ее Наша команда волонтерів однодумців
добровольців не залишає вас сам на сам з
вашими проблемами для того щоби ви
вірили і допомога прийде і все буде
добре І щоб ви з оптимізмом дивилися в
майбутнє бо українці вони сильні коли
вони разом давайте бути разом давайте
об'єднаємося і дамо відці і Путіна з
його агресією і пандемії і цим зеленим
неробом які на сьогоднішній день
намагаються знищити нашу державу Ми
Точно спільно разом їм цього не
дозволимо зробити
дякую
дякую оце постійне рипіння скотчу на
фоні це ж пакують продуктові набори
розумієте і у нас тут конвеєр повним
ходом тому Хлопці вже завантажують
наступний он ще одну палету привезли А
скільки на такій палеті цікаво наборів я
от хлопці а скільки на такій палеті
наборів 80 80 наборів тобто одна така
палета 80 наборів і таких палет зробили
вже просто хто зна
скільки
що ж друзі Дякую за те що дивились цей
стрім дивіться в описі до відео
координати як допомогти нам і поширюйте
будь ласка цей стрім тому що я думаю що
це важливо поба